[Music]
so there's a lot of Cruz isms in here so
I did pull the word blazer because I
knew you were gonna like that I'm
interested to see what its gonna look
like on it feels really casual right now
but I feel like once we put it on yeah
let's try this stuff long I think
it's game time Victor what you're gonna
see today is guys when you're doing this
you don't just like take your clothes
and wear him home it's all about the
flip and it really knows as well so yeah
that's my mantra I mean that was like
the first one of the first things that
Cruz and I talked about in when he and I
met and we went through his closet
together you know and I did a closet
assessment for him there were great
things that he had in his closet and I'm
like well let's try it on and let's
retailer it and resize it and see how
you feel in it and once I resized one
thing he wouldn't wear any of his other
like I know sometimes you're little
hesitant when she's taking all your
clothes she's like well we can do this
and I was like hold on I wear a lot of
that stuff you can't go and tailor it so
I gave her a few pieces I was lenient
and they came back and I put it on I was
like Rachel I'm giving you everything
and another thing that guys should also
know is like your tailor should be like
your barber so once you found your
tailor just like you go to your barber
and he knows how you want your haircut
and you go to him every week and he
knows your tailor should be the same way
like Taylor Bible barber
I've had my barber since I was 14 Friday
Tuesday so it's the perfect it's all
about your look you know your hair and
so Levi let's let's give to be sneezes
what did we do here that that a guy at
home can be learning from though like
when I'm ready to do it right I'm just
like take it from all the scenes in step
one seems just to keep a shape we
talking GQ all the time about slimming
it down and bringing it in you don't
have to have a great body a lot of
things look like we've taken guys who
work just like importantly and you know
you but you and they think again they're
swimming in these suits or like you know
as Victor and I have talked about saying
yeah well that slim Bing is like for
those other guys but in fact you slim it
down and you look slimmer and you look
more fit and I mean these clothes are
not tight on you are they exactly
no no it still throw punch want to do
this shirt before Rachel got ahold of
your closet and what was your I your I
was in a different place you you thought
[ __ ] was in you thought it was still
like as we always say speaking of ESPN
we talked about guys on draft day
showing up in the bad suits but once I
met Rachel and I started to open up my
world about you know tailoring and how
it should look and how it can be slimmer
and it still looks like you and it
doesn't really guys in the locker room
as you I mean yes they do
yes you know those pants are a little
too tight you know and I my response
every time was like no my pants fit I'll
take that because you're your style
setter yeah I mean somebody has to do it
first right there and to make it okay
why you need to wear what you feel great
a new me
you